I won't let anything happen to her we
were so happy with how frozen two ended
Anna you really grew up and matured a
lot your relationship with Elsa is even
stronger Olaf has shown you what true
friendship is all about and you and
Kristoff are absolutely made for each
other you totally saved the day and we
know that arendelle's future is going to
be awesome because of you it was such a
happy ending Rosen too is finally out
and it is epic but some questions just
didn't get answered keep watching to
find out these 10 burning questions but
beware spoilers are ahead waking up the
forest when Elsa sings into the unknown
she refuses the call to the north at
first but then all of a sudden her magic
burst forth with ice diamonds full of
symbols these symbols are all the
elements she says she woke the spirits
of the Enchanted Forest but how did she
know how to do that and what exactly did
she do Olaf's intuition
Olaf is still one of the best characters
in the movie he's so hilarious and so
sweet
forgive me maturity is making me poetic
but he's also the world's smartest
snowman he has a lot of insight into
philosophical questions he says that
enchanted forests bring transformation
but he doesn't know what transformation
means he intuitively knows the wind
spirit when he meets it how does he know
all of these things talking reindeer
Kristoff met his counterpart in writer
they both swear that they know what
reindeer are thinking and they give them
voices but do they really know what the
reindeer are thinking do they have some
sort of superhuman animal communication
skills also spend does talking Kristoff
song was that a hallucination or did
spend really speak the whole thing with
the reindeer needed more explanation how
far away Disney really glossed over the
geographical distances in frozen to when
they go to the enchanted forest
it seems like a long trip it was an
effort Olaf to annoy them and Elsa to
fall asleep but then it says the forest
is on the st. George
it doesn't appear to take them long to
travel the whole forest or for
so to go to the glacier but the glacier
looked further on her parents map and at
the end of the movie also showed up to
save arendelle really quickly wedding
bells christophe finally gets the chance
to propose and he doesn't mess it up ice
then we fast-forward to anna as queen of
arendelle have they gotten married yet
we just don't know if the wedding has
happened keep watching to find out even
bigger questions that didn't get
answered different dimension when Elsa
goes to the magical glacier it seems
very real but then she goes through a
passage and ends up walking through what
looks like stars memories appear around
her and that chamber just didn't look
big enough for all that Elsa saw there
did Elsa pass through into some magical
dimension does the place only exist for
her because she's the fifth spirit earth
spirits the enchanted forest has the
spirits of all the elements Bruni is the
totally adorable fire spirit the horse
is the water spirit and Gale is the wind
spirit but then there are the earth
Giants there are a bunch of them but
these are implied to be the earth spirit
even Elsa as the fifth spirit is only
one entity why does the earth have
several spirits instead of just one
saving Elsa Anna knew that Elsa would go
too far and she did she ended up
freezing and possibly even passing away
since her magic faded honest said Elsa
gave her life for the truth about the
past on a nude the only way to free the
forest and save arendelle was to destroy
the dam but that didn't explain how Elsa
suddenly came back to life the dam
wasn't magical so how did it save Elsa
strange language Elsa and Anna discover
a scroll in their parents shipwreck it's
in a strange language that neither of
them knows but we have a lot of
questions about this first of all what
language is it is it North aldrin second
what did it say and finally was this the
same strange language her parents read
in the first movie to find the trolls we
want answers
time passed frozen to was very precise
about how long the forest had been
launched 34 years 5 months and 23 days
but the rest of the time
the mystery we don't know how much time
has passed between the first two movies
we don't know how long they were in the
forest and we don't know how much time
passes between saving the forest and the
jump to the future when Ana's queen if
you thought frozen 2 was beyond epic
subscribe to the things and don't forget
to click that notification bell we'll be
posting all about the new movie and
other Disney films if you're watching on
mobile make sure you have notifications
turned on to never miss another video
can you guess the answers to some of
these questions sound off in the
comments that's a wrap give this video a
big thumbs up if you like warm hugs
thanks for watching
[Music]